Es geht um zum Beispiel um Schiffe, Panzer,
Drohnen und Raketenwerfer mit künstlicher
Intelligenz.
Sie sind im Krieg in der Lage, selbstständig
Ziele zu erkennen und zu zerstören.
Menschen haben bei der Entscheidung über
Leben und Tod nichts mehr zu sagen.
Dazu kommt: Roboter, die in den Krieg geschickt
werden, töten natürlich auch Menschen.
Kritiker sind alarmiert, denn solche Kampfeinsätze
sind höchst umstritten.
Ein Treffen bei den Vereinten Nationen in
Genf hat jetzt genau diese Frage diskutiert:
Dürfen Roboter selbstständig Menschen töten
oder soll das schnellstmöglich verboten werden?
Die Antwort ist mehr als erschreckend.
Alle wichtigen Facts zu dem hochspannenden
Thema bekommt ihr jetzt hier - Herzlich willkommen
bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Soll dieses Menschenleben jetzt ausgelöscht
werden oder nicht?
Diese Entscheidung könnte in einem zukünftigen
Krieg einzig und allein bei Robotern liegen.
Solche autonomen Waffen werden durch Künstliche
Intelligenz möglich.
Die Maschinen lernen, wie ein Ziel aussieht,
wie es sich bewegt und wann es angegriffen
wird.
Entscheidungen von Menschen sind dann völlig
überflüssig.
Der Roboter zündet selbstständig.
Also eindeutig noch einmal einen Schritt weiter
als sogenannte automatische Waffen, die zwar
automatisch schießen - bei dem das Ziel im
Vorfeld aber durch einen Menschen klar definiert
wurde.
Fachleute sind sich einig, dass beispielsweise
Russland, die USA, Großbritannien und Südkorea
an solchen Systemen tüfteln.
Neil Davison vom Internationalen Komitee des
Roten Kreuzes ist dagegen felsenfest davon
überzeugt, dass sie schon jetzt existieren.
Dabei sind viele Dinge unklar: Können solche
Killer-Roboter beispielsweise erkennen, ob
ein Feind verletzt ist oder sich gerade ergeben
will?
Versteht solch eine tödliche Maschine auch,
dass der Gegenüber zwar eine Waffe trägt,
aber nur Jäger ist und keinesfalls Soldat?
Fragen über Fragen und eine der größten
Sorgen machen die moralischen Aspekte.
Beispielsweise: Wer wird für die Entscheidungen
über Leben und Tod zur Verantwortung gezogen,
wenn es keine Menschen mehr sind, die die
Entscheidungen treffen?!
Das humanitäre Völkerrecht wird durch den
Einsatz dieser Waffensysteme früher später
beschnitten werden.
Demnach sind Angriffe auf militärische Ziele
zu beschränken - doch wie sollen Maschinen
das entscheiden?
Das ganze Thema ist hochkomplex und super
wichtig!
Und genau deswegen hatten sich Ende August
70 Diplomaten und Regierungsvertreter aus
aller Welt in Genf getroffen.
Das Ziel: die Kontrolle über solche autonomen
Waffen.
Dazu Thomas Küchenmeister, der Mitglied der
internationalen Kampagne gegen Killerroboter,
ist: „Waffen können nicht zwischen Freund
und Feind unterscheiden und gehören auf den
völkerrechtlichen Prüfstand“.
So oder so ähnlich sehen das auch mehr als
2000 Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler,
die in ihrem Fachbereich mit künstlicher
Intelligenz zu tun haben und autonome Waffen
von Grund auf verurteilen.
Deswegen haben sie einen Appell an die Regierungen
weltweit verfasst.
Unter anderem dabei ist auch Elon Musk.
In dem Schreiben heißt es unter anderem:
“Wir dürfen Maschinen keine Entscheidung
über Leben und Tod überlassen, für die
andere - oder niemand - strafbar gemacht werden.
(...) Tausende KI-Forscher sind sich einig,
dass tödliche autonome Waffen (...) zu mächtigen
Instrumenten der Gewalt und Unterdrückung
werden könnten, insbesondere wenn sie mit
Überwachungs- und Datensystemen verbunden
sind.”
Mit ihrer Unterschrift leisten die Forscherinnen
und Forscher das Versprechen, sich niemals
an der Entwicklung solcher Waffensysteme zu
beteiligen.
Sie fordern Technologiefirmen weltweit auf,
es ihnen gleich zu tun.
Zudem appellieren sie auch an Politiker und
Regierungen, endlich Vorschriften und Gesetze
zu schaffen, die eine Welt ohne tödliche
autonome Waffen garantieren.
Dennoch sind die Verhandlungen in Genf in
Sachen Killerroboter gestern ohne Einigung
beendet worden.
Es gibt kein offizielles Abschlusspapier,
obwohl sich der Großteil der Teilnehmer dafür
ausgesprochen hatte, Verhandlungen über das
Thema zu führen.
Um dadurch eine neue internationale Gesetzgebung
Realität werden zu lassen.
Doch eine kleine Gruppe von Rüstungs-Mächten
war wohl dagegen.
Allen voran offensichtlich die USA und Israel,
die sich gegen eine gegen eine internationale
Regelung ausgesprochen haben.
Vorreiterrollen nahmen dagegen Deutschland
und Franlkreich ein, die zunächst einen Verhaltenskodex
vorgeschlagen hatten.
Als Kompromiss hatten beide Länder zudem
eine politische Erklärung gefordert, nach
der Menschen zumindest weiterhin die letzten
Entscheidungen über den Einsatz der autonomen
Waffen fällen könnten.
Die Haltung der deutschen Bundesrepublik in
diesem Kontext ist sogar im Koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten: “Autonome Waffensysteme, die
der Verfügung des Menschen entzogen sind,
lehnen wir ab.
Wir wollen sie weltweit ächten.“
Dennoch kamen die die Diskussionsteilnehmer
in Genf nicht zu dem dringend notwendigen
Konsens.
Dazu der US-Vertreter Karl Chang: “Aus US-Sicht
liegt kein Wert an sich darin, eine Waffe
von Menschenhand zu bedienen und nicht durch
ein autonomes System”.
Dieses “Ergebnis” oder besser “Nicht-Ergebnis”
ist mehr als alarmierend und riskant für
uns alle!
Die schlimmsten Albträume vor denen Stephen
Hawking und Elon Musk gewarnt haben könnten
so Realität werden.
Waffensysteme mit künstlicher Intelligenz
übernehmen die Macht!
Und jetzt: Clixoom wird werbefrei!
Keine Prerolls mehr.
Mit eurer Hilfe.
Immer wenn wir entsprechend viele Kanalmitglieder
gewonnen haben, schalten wir die Werbung vor
jeweils einem Video im Monat ab.
Bald ist es beim ersten Video soweit.
Werdet also Mitglied!
Hier unter dem Video draufklicken und bekommt
noch exklusive Extravideos, exklusive Livestreams
wie kommenden Dienstag und noch ein paar weitere
Privilegien!
Einen riesen Dank an all diejenigen, die schon
dabei sind!!
Es werden immer mehr!
Wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle Videos
informiert werden wollt, dann added mich übrigens
bei WhatsApp.
Dann bekommt ihr den Link zum Video vor allen
anderen von mir persönlich auf euer Handy.
Einfach hier draufklicken.
Hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf auch
klicken) „Künstliche Intelligenz entwickelt
sich immer schneller!“
Bis dann, bleibt dran!